Berto Rico je suis venu ici à la recherche d'
une histoire
qui s'appelle du journalisme ton CV n'a pas l'
air si anxieux je n'aurais pas payé
ton hôtel si je ne t'avais pas déjà embauché
mais j'ai trouvé le paradis le plus étrange sur
terre
hé ta dame a pensé  tu as dit que tu avais une
télé le gars de l'autre côté de la ruelle à la télé
j'ai des jumelles c'est là que tes
secrets viennent danser ne remarque pas la
perruque et un vaudou fonctionne c'est magique
laisse boire ne te
cause
pas d'ennuis comment quelqu'un boit  cent
soixante et une miniatures ne sont-elles pas
complémentaires peut-être que vous étiez dans le
Connecticut restez loin d'elle
elle est le fiancé de Sanderson elle est quelques
jours nue secouez-la comme des maracas
elle est une douce petite beauté je le
regardais tous les deux nous avons tous été en bas
sur elle c'est une expérience merveilleuse c'est
plus simple
maintenant tout cela peut ressembler à une
hallucination folle mais c'est tout à fait vrai
je pense que c'est l'endroit pour voir si l'argent Paul
et il y a des gens comme moi vous savez
comment le sortir n'est pas si mince  g
tout c'est une venue inappropriée
nous avons cloué ce bâtard à sa propre
porte d'entrée j'ai une histoire pour vous
qui vous poursuit hors de votre esprit je parie que
vous avez crié avant moi
parce qu'une chose comme 407 objectif d'évaluation
ce que nous faisons est une
façade privée  les sièges ont disparu, j'ai une idée géniale,
essayez d'avoir l'air normal